all right
um well welcome everyone by dave thank
you for having me
and everyone in the audience thank you
for being with me
my name is hugh paters i'm the cto of
insomnia
and we're an ai based consultancy firm
out of amsterdam
uh you might know us from the
self-driving vote
adventure or which now turned into a
venture
or many other projects wait let me see
okay
[Music]
ah like that is better and a big shout
out to them for sponsoring this talk
uh and giving me any time to prepare uh
talk will be about python from source to
execution
so we're gonna follow a very simple code
snippet and see how it eventually ends
up
as machine code on your cpu and we're
gonna sort of high level follow all the
steps
that it takes well why bother
well sometimes python can feel like this
magical language where
everything just works and you duct type
everything together
and sometimes it can be very frustrating
when something doesn't work
and i think it was last year when we
were at lunch here in the office and we
were sort of discussing
what actually happens in the background
once you start a
python program i mean some mentioned
there is a compiler some say no
it cannot be the case it's an
interpreted language and it sort of
got me wondering what actually happens
and it left me in a path
to the python internals and i want to
take you guys
with this journey inside these python
internals
is it useful as a python programmer well
one could say
no do i really need to know how a car
works if i want to drive a car
maybe not but it might you'll help you
out in a certain edge case
or it might help explain something
that's happening
if you don't understand it very well and
overall it's just really good to know
how stuff works and how stuff runs
i would argue at least so our journey
begins with this very simple code
snippet
it's an assignment it's a one plus two
uh it's not really that difficult and
hopefully or
maybe obviously your code is going to be
a lot more difficult than this
but i guess this is enough complexity
for
explaining in half an hour so it's an
assignment
um it's an if where we check if the
number is even well in this case you all
figured out probably it's not
so it will print out odd and we're sort
of going to follow this this statement
on onto how it gets executed
i sort of separate it into four steps
the the elixir
the parser the compiler and the
interpreter
in reality sort of the lecture and
parser are a bit more intertwined but
it makes it so much more easier to
explain if we separate them
so bear with me for the ones who already
know the internals
and the goal of the the lecter is to
separate your source code into a
sequence of tokens
so it's quite similar to how text mining
grabs a piece of text
and separates that text into a number of
words
well similarly our tokenizer grabs our
our source code like a giant string and
then
separates it into tokens
a token can be for instance a name or an
operator
and these are predefined and also
in the token we define where in the line
it occurs
and on what character within that line
so we sort of have the debug
information available to us later if we
want to move back to it
let's say we were to deviate from our
from our very
basic example and we were to pass in an
invalid statement let's say if if
our tokenizer would be very fine in
tokenizing this i mean
the tokenizer itself does not have the
the rules of the language so to say so
you can pass in invalid statements
and it will just give you back the
sequence of tokens because it's not its
job to actually
check hey is this valid python or not
it's just it's just splitting it up and
it's available in the tokenized module
in the standard library
it's a fully written python tokenizer
so the second part is the is the parser
and the parser sort of
goal is a bit i'll say it's a bit too
full so
one we still need to do this check if
it's actually correct syntax
and the second goal is we need to change
from the sequence of token
tokens into an a better representation
a better representation for the compiler
to work with and one
that most languages use is the abstract
syntax tree sort of a tree
that's easy to visit easy to follow
along and easy to transform
so the parser yeah we i just
heard it mentioned that it's it's going
to receive a major overhaul in python
3.9
and this is by the way already the
sample of the python grammar for the
for the new uh python 3.9
it's going to change from look ahead one
parser to
something else called the back parser
partial expression grammar
and we'll dive into it in a bit but the
grammar sort of contains
the rules of the language and also the
easter egg by the way
um and you can you can have rules for
instance the top rule is a file rule
and it states that the file rule has
let me grab the pointer so it has the
file rule
and it has exist consists of a number of
statements followed by an end marker
and this grammar is sort of a let's call
it a giant configuration file for the
parser generator so the parser generator
will grab
this grammar and generate all the source
code for us
to actually check the for validity of
the syntax
and eventually also create the ast
so let's uh let's follow our simple
example and let's only follow our first
statement because
otherwise we're going to take too long
um we'll see our statement consist of
the name token the operator token number
operator number
new line and marker and then we'll move
on to the
first rule so we'll move on to the
module and then we'll see
statement followed by and marker
so how you can sort of explain it is
it's going to recursively descend
into the first alternative every time up
until it succeeds
and then it might check for the
alternatives if they're a better or
longer match
uh it will use those but in our simple
example we're just going to check for
first alternative for first
alternatives so we'll check
for the statement so we'll dive into the
statement rule
and we'll check for the first
alternative which is an expression
followed by a new line we'll dive into
the expression rule
which is an atom followed by a plus sign
followed by another expression
uh and eventually we'll dive down into
an atom which is either a name or a
number
and our first token is a name so
we can go back here and say okay yeah
that's right our first token is indeed
an atom
and then we go to the second one which
is a plus sign
well our second token is not a plus sign
it's an equal sign
so we sort of reject this alternative
and we go into the second alternative
and say okay
by similar fashion and this is all
cached so it's a lot quicker than
than it seems um we'll go again find an
atom followed by a minus sign um well
our second token is also not a minus
sign
so that's also invalid
and then we move on to our third
alternative which says okay it's an atom
well this is the case so it can also be
an expression consisting only of an atom
and we'll bubble back upwards to our
expression
to our statement rule but there we see
it's not and
followed by a new line because our token
our name token
is followed by an operator token so we
sort of
reject the first alternative
and well you could do it yourself but
assume that the assignment also works on
the statements
so eventually we'll parse the assignment
followed by a new line
we'll bubble back upwards to the module
and then we'll find that it's
it has the end marker as well so we
successfully uh checked for syntax for
this um
check the grammar for this statement
um so we sort of finished with our with
our first task in the parser
and our second task was to create a
better representation a tree structure
and one way we could do this is just
following
and matching the tree according to the
rules of the grammar so we could have as
a root note we could have the module
followed by a statement followed by an
assignment and then we could
basically everything that's in the
grammar we could parse it into a tree
this is typically called a parse stream
it's also how the old grammar uh used
what the old grammar used as a sort of
intermediate representation
the problem with the parse tree is it's
quite for both and it's
tightly coupled with our grammar and our
grammar is the easiest way for us to
write but it's not maybe the easiest way
to convey the information
so so that's where the second language
comes in
uh sort of description language and we
describe
part of the notes we describe the nodes
that can occur so we have the module
node we have a statement node
which can either be an expression or
assignment it's quite similar to
the grammar but it's a bit more easy to
work with and it does not need all the
syntax and
comments and stuff so we can basically
leave that out
um how we're going to do that is we're
going to add actions to our grammar
so you can see them in between the curly
braces
those are our actions so to say so when
we successfully
parse a certain rule um we'll bind it to
the variable a
and that variable a gets then passed or
a and b
gets them passed to the node and we
construct that node
if we follow the same example earlier
we'll end up with
the xx syntax tree that is on the right
where we see a module
followed by assignment and then the name
the binary operator
although this is a sort of simplified
example the real world
the ast is not very far from it
here i import the ast module which is in
the standard library
and i used another module which i don't
think is in the standard library
sort of to pretty print um the astr
and you see again the same thing you
have a module
you have a body which can be a list of
statements
and you have the assign assign node
which has
targets in this case because python can
have multiple targets for one assign
and so this and well all the rest
which is a bit the same as what we had
before
so now we have this this beautiful asd
structure which is a really convenient
structure to work with
um for instance when you see tools like
black
and they they start code formatting your
your
your code and eventually they'll use the
asd to sort of check hey
is this still the same code does it
still do the same thing
because if the asds are the same you
know they're semantically the same
um smart refactorings will also use this
asd to check for things like double
negatives
and other things but i think that
python optimizer also does that
so we successfully parsed our statement
into
an ast and we're at the third step which
is i think
one of the more difficult steps is to
compile these statements
and the asd is nice it's a good
representation but the interpreter
needs bytecode and can only run bytecode
so we need this compiler to compile our
ast
into bytecode and
as a kid i was always baffled by
computers and how they work
and i really like the statement because
i think it explains it very very well
in our cpus that we have in our
computers are sort of
seem always this complicated stuff but
in the end it's
it's like a rock that we tricked into
thinking so we have hard-coded
into the silicon a number of
instructions
these are sort of like the instruction
set the things it can do
and the python interpreter is not that
much different i am
you can look at the operation codes
there are about i think 150 of them
and these are sort of the instructions
that the interpreter can understand
so for instance if we supply the number
23
to our interpreter it will perform a
binary add
operation so all the source code that we
have gets
transformed into an ast and the goal of
the compiler is to
create a sequence of bytecode
corresponding
to these operation codes such that it's
similar to the asd
such as it can execute the asd
it's available uh in the standard
library again with the compile function
now here it's even a smaller snippet
it's just a oneplus two
um and the compile function will give
you back a code object
um i'll discuss that a bit later but one
the most important attribute of your
code object
is in co underscore code and that's the
byte code
it's easier to look at if you use the
disassembler so we use the
disassembler module and then we see load
constant
0 load constant 1 binary add and return
value
for the ones who are already familiar
with python internals
i this is i disabled the optimizer
so the optimizer will optimize this away
and we'll say load constant three
but for the sake of simplicity i
disabled all optimizations
and well you see this load constant and
another load constant
and what python means when it says load
constant or load anything
is that it has a sequence of bytecode
instructions
and in order to keep a sort of state it
uses a stack
and it implements the stack for a lot of
things but this thing
when you refer to is the value stack
because you load
values onto the stack and then you
perform operations
on those values so first you load the
constant one
then you load the constant two you
perform binary add which sort of pops
two things off the stack
and returns it onto the stack and then
eventually you return whatever
is on top of the stack
so what we could do is we could we could
convert all our instructions to the
corresponding byte code
and just by following them one by one
but we'll run into
two sort of problems
the first one relates to variables or
our name bindings as they're often
referred to in python
is that if you use a variable
python needs to know what the scope of
this variable is the compiler needs to
know this either it needs to say oh i
need to load this from the global
namespace
or i can load it fast from the local
namespace
so it needs to have some sort of idea if
it encounters a variable
where this variable is defined and what
its scope is
there are three scopes local global they
sort of speak for themselves
and then you have free which is that
it's
declared somewhere in an enclosing scope
that's
especially true for things like closures
so before we actually compile our uh
our statements into bytecode we
construct a symbolic table
and in type languages for instance like
c this is the place where you would
actually
check hey is the variable declared does
it have the right type do you return the
right type
and if not it will give you a bunch of
errors well python does not do that but
it needs to know
the symbolic table for this scoping
because the scopes are
important in order to create the right
instructions
and then another challenge we have is
control flow
so if we were to just go statement by
statement out of the ast
we'll run into a bit of an issue that if
we evaluate this if statement
um we'll see the sort of spaghetti code
in action
if we run this if statement um we we're
going to print r so we're going to skip
a part
but if we are compiling we don't know
where to skip to just yet because we're
not there
we don't know where it's going to jump
to because we're
compiling still and we haven't seen that
part
and this is especially true for all
things that change control flow
um we need to know where to jump to and
we need to know
how to create the right byte code for
that
so how python approaches this is with
something called the control flow graph
so it splits up the all the instructions
you have
into basic blocks and these basic blocks
they have
one entry point and can have multiple
exit points
so here we split up our our stuff in in
basic blocks
we have num equals one plus two we have
our again if
if this is true print even if it's false
we'll print out and then we
return none that's uh in this case
python always returns something
so return none is added
and the nice thing about these basic
blocks is we can
convert them into python byte code
there's nothing because there's only one
entry point
and we can convert the stuff we
there's nothing holding us back from
converting everything to
to python byte code the only thing
that's sort of a problem
is these jumps because although we know
these basic blocks exist
we still don't know their offset or we
still don't know where we're going to
put them
so we can sort of leave the jumps out a
bit and just
put the reference that we need to jump
to a certain basic block
and then it is the job of the assembler
to assemble all these basic blocks
together and think of them like lego you
you start at the easiest you start at
the one where there are no jumps and
then
eventually you solve everything by sort
of like depth first search
and you can resolve all the offsets so
sort of looks like this this is the
bytecode these are the white code
instructions for our
simple code snippet and we can see that
it added two jumps
so here pop jump if false which means
if the compare operator pushed its
results onto the stack
the statement is going to pop that off
the stack if
the comparison was false it's going to
jump to 30
or it's going to print odd if it's true
it's just going to continue like normal
and print even and eventually jump
forward
to skip over the print out and this
these are sort of all the instructions
that we need
um what you might see is that
python byte code is always written in a
word so it's one
instruction one byte for the op code and
one byte for the op
argument so it does not say load
constant
even basically it says load constant
three
and this is an index into a certain
attribute in our code
object so we have our code object here
again with the compile function
and we'll print out everything that's
that's relevant to us
again we see our our attribute co code
which is our code object
but we're also seeing co constant so
this
this three we saw earlier means index
three and the co constants are even
um we'll see variables uh zero names
cover names
salvars free vars these all relate to
their relevant scope
and we'll also have a line number table
which is sort of the mapping
from our original source code uh into
bytecode so we can
debugging we know what is actually
executing
and some other things that are a bit
less relevant like stack size
and that's it for the compiler so the
compiler's job is done now
we've we've created this thing called
the code object
and we're sort of ready to to execute
well
almost ready because think of the code
objects
as blueprints so sort of contain
everything you need
in order to execute but you still need
some sort of environment
and this is where the the frame object
comes in
so the frame object will have the code
it will have all the all the variables
we'll have this value stack we've been
talking about
and it it has a
pointer to uh to another frame object so
frame objects can can be
listed together in like a linked list
fashion so let's say you
you call a function python does it will
push a new frame
put the reference and then run the code
the code object of that function
so these frames are sort of where
everything happens
and everything comes together they're
the blueprints
and the environment
to give you like you can see the frame
with the assist.underscore git frame
line
doesn't really hold much relevant
information it's way easier to go into
the
see python code itself but
a nice exercise to see
so in the end what actually happens when
you when you start a python program and
you start
uh you initialize an interpreter state
you create a
thread state um and this
you basically pass in the cli arguments
the environment variables or stuff like
this
and all this together with the code
objects get passed to the frame
which is something we can actually
execute
and the frame object is
is where all the magic happens and
if it's it's the part where it actually
has the the byte code
and remember the the cpu example where
we had
cpu basically tricked it into thinking
by understanding
a small set of instructions
the same thing is for our example with
our interpreter our python interpreter
you can also understand
a bunch of a bunch of instructions like
these
and it comes together in a
giant case switch statement to me it's a
bit ironic it's also a bit funny that
um the heart at the heart of python
there is a case switch statement
but inside the python programming
language itself there is not
the case which statement and not because
they don't
the developers don't want to add it but
because it got voted out
for not adding enough
and in this c code we can sort of see
the instructions
funnily enough was also mentioned in a
slide earlier by
james powell where he was talking about
the micro optimization here
um so what were to happen is we popped
the two things off the stack
and here we have an optimization saying
okay if they're both unicode
we go into this function otherwise we go
into this by number
add which does not necessarily need to
be a number
um it just looks up the type
of of the left variable and then we'll
perform the relevant edition you can
overload that parameter overload that
method of course
uh you you push back the thing on the
on the stack again so setup and this is
really the heart where
the execution occurs so now we sort of
completed full circle
we've seen our statement we've seen how
it got tokenized into a sequence of
tokens
we've seen the parser check for validity
of the syntax
and create this abstract syntax tree
um we compiled it into a code object
which contains the python white code
together with
the constant variable names and such and
then we had the interpreter create a
frame for us
which was the environment to run
and we fed it and we streamed in all the
all the bytecode instructions and we're
executing our compiled
c python code on our cpu so that's sort
of the whole
whole journey in a nutshell
of course i skip over many things
there's still a lot to talk about
generators function calls
the python object model and there's
still a lot to figure out
and if you're interested in this topic
uh the top two are really good books
on the python virtual machine or python
interpreter or however you want to call
them
um if you're interested in the new pack
parser there's great
block series by hido it's nine parts on
on how it works and also how the parser
generator works how the meta parser
generator works
uh it's a very nice explanation and of
course if all else fails
there is always the source code to look
at available on github